Philippe et son père arrivent de Québec
c'est la première fois qu'il participe à
une manifestation à Montréal
oui on est vrai le jeune militants de 17
ans sont-elles urgence d'agir
manifester travailler son réseau sans
consommation radio c'est moins c'est ça
qui est important de l'espoir il en faut
devant le pied de finement des
négociations à la coupe 15 Esmeralda
fait partie de la délégation jeunesse
qui assiste aux discussions mais ce
qu'on voit c'est que souvent nos
priorités ne sont pas reflétées dans les
textes finaux et qu'en plus les
négociations sont extrêmement longues
c'est donc à l'extérieur des murs du
palais des congrès que les manifestants
veulent lancer un message il faut
travailler sur le paradigme économique
sur notre surconsommation sur la course
à la croissance effrénée tant qu'on ne
redonnera pas adresser ça on y arrivera
pas passer des paroles aux actes donc on
est là aujourd'hui pour marcher toute
jeune olive elle demande aux adultes
d'agir pour que les autres personnes
[Musique]
et les Premières nations sont au
première loge de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité malgré le fait que on est
des personnes qui ont à prendre la vie
le vivant on sait que notre
responsabilité maintenant c'est à notre
retour mettre notre énergie au profit du
vivant et si on veut espérer ne
serait-ce que nos enfants nos
petits-enfants puissent voir l'avenir
Philippe a serré la main de Gabriel
Nadou Dubois le jeune militant fait
encore confiance aux dirigeants pour
régler la crise mais cette COP15 doit
donner des résultats concrets
littéralement trahi puis je pense pas
que je serai la seule personne
il serait des milliers à se sentir trahi
la pression est immense sur les
négociateurs de la COP15 ici Marie José
Paquette commune Radio-Canada Montréal